سنتوقف مع فاصل مشاهدينا نعود من بعده
لنتابع كل هذه التفاصيل ولكن سنبدا بملفنا
الثاني في اخر تطورات الوضع الميداني في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه التوتر الامني لا يزال
متواصلا لينظر بالمزيد من التصعيد مع
مواصله المستوطنين الاسرائيليين اقتحام
باحه المسجد الاقصى اسرائيل دقت سفارات
الانذار في مستوطنه اضافيه بالجليل الغربي
بعد ضربات الصاروخيه التي نفذت من جنوب
لبنان تجاهات الابيب والتي خلقت حاله من
التاهب القصوى تصاحبها اجتماعات ومشاورات
يعقدها نتنياهو مع قاده الجيش والامن
فتسلط الضوء على الاحداث في الاقصى ومساله
الامن يمكن ان يخدم
الذين يتعرضان لضغوط داخليه ترجمتها
المظاهرات الاخيره في تل ابيب نتنياهو
يسعى لكسب الوقت لتهدئه الشارع الاسرائيلي
ولتمرير القراءه الثانيه والثالثه على
التعديلات القضائيه ليكون هو المستفيد على
صعيد الداخليه مما يحدث خصوصا وانه بذل
جهودا حثثه لخلق ثغره قانونيه تلتف على
القانون الاسرائيلي الذي يحول دون ان
يتبول الملاحقون قضائيا المناصب الوزاريه
ليس هدف حسب بل تعهد بمواصله المساعي
لاجراء التعديلات القضائيه التي من شانها
ان تمنح الكنيسه الاسرائيلي صلاحيات واسعه
على حساب القضاء كما انا بنكير على
الجهتين يعتبر مستفيدا لان الاقتحامات
للمسجد الاقصى كانت من ضمن حملته
الانتخابيه السابقه ولم يتوقف عن الدعوه
لاقتحام الاقصى
خطه تعديل النظام القضائي في اسرائيل
مشروع طرحه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
مشروع التعديل يهدف الى الحد من المراقبه
القضائيه لتشريعات
منح السياسيين سلطات اكبر في اسرائيل
سيطره الحكومه على تعيينات القضاه معارض
الخطه يرون بانها تهدف لتقويض السلطه
القضائيه لصالح السلطه السياسيه مشروع
نتنياهو اججج الشارع الاسرائيلي ضده وخلق
ضغوطا كبيره عليها مراقبون يرون ان
نتنياهو يستغل الوضع الامني لتخفيف
الاحتقان الداخلي ضده عبر خلق تهديد من
غزه يمنع الاسرائيليين من التظاهر ضد
ائتلافه الحكومي
مساء الخير لك ولديك المشاهدين والمشاهدات
هو سؤال صحيح في محله لان يعني رمضان
المفروض انه ياتينا بحله جديده نريد فيها
ان يكون شهر الصيام والتسامح وتعبد واعاده
المسجد الاقصى المبارك يشهد تدفقا من
الجماهير ربع مليون ونصف مليون انسان
كما يظهر هذا يريد قوى اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل التي لا تريد ان ترى المنطقه
بحضور عربي او اسلامي وشاهدنا ايضا في
الاونه الاخيره اعتداءات ايضا على اماكن
العباده المسيحيه في القدس وهذا ليس سلطه
كله مع بعض لان المستفيد الاساسي منه هو
ذلك التيار الذي اصبح اليوم شريكا في
الحكم ومؤثرا للغايه اليمين المتطرف الذي
لديه خطه واضحه مكتوبه اسود على ابيض
ومعروفه ومكشوفه ونشرت في صحافه اسرائيل
ايضا
هي خطه الحسم التي وضعها الوزير في وزاره
الامن والتي ترمي الى اشعه الفوضى في
المناطق الفلسطينيه اسقاط السلطه
الفلسطينيه وبدا مشعور المشروع للتصفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه تماما
هل يستفيد نتنياهو من هذا التصعيد من هذه
الاحداث خاصه وانه عاش على وقت على وقع
متابعه مظاهرات
شملت اكثر من 130 نقطه في داخل الاسرائيلي
وفجاه اندلعت هذه المواجهات في المشهد
الاقصى وكان البعض لاهته مثل هكذا
الشبكات
فريحت نتنياهو بشكل او باخر ما رايك
مساء الخير
والمشاهدين ورمضان كريم اصدار هني
اما بخصوص سؤالك
هذا ليس بصحيح مطلقا الدوله الاسرائيليه
مهما كانت الحكومه التي تسودها لها مصلحه
بالحفاظ للامن الداخلي وتعتبرني الخارجي
وذلك يعني بغيت قصف الشرعيه لدوله التي
تتيح حريه الاباده للجميع وليس هناك احد
الذي يريد عمدا
اثاره اثاره اي مشاغبات او مشاكل في
القدس او في اي مكان اخر خاصه مش بالاقصى
الشريف عندما
يعني يقول شهر رمضان المبارك له
باثاره المشاكل في الاقصى هوم الحركات
التنزيمات الارابيه الفلسطينيه وعلى راسي
يا حماس التي اطلقت قبل سنه
صاروخين
ليسوا فقط مستوطنين متطرفين من اجتاح
الاقصى هم الشرطه وزير الشرطه بنكير هو
الذي كان يدعو دكتور دكتور ان كنت تسمعني
او سنخفف من الصوت تسمعني دكتور
طيب نخفف الصوت يبدو بان ضيفي لا يسمعني
نحاول ان نعود له بعد قليل لانه نحن
نتفاعل كذلك يجب ان لا يمر كل الكلام
الدكتور اهو فين تسمعني
اتفاعل مع حضرتك لما اتفاعل معك فقط
تسمعني تسمح لي بالتعليق تسمعني وفيما بعد
تستكمل فكرتك لانك تقول سيد رافين حضرتك
تقول كل الدخل الاسرائيلي يطمح لتحقيق
الامن في داخل فلسطيني ولكن كيف ذلك وزير
الشرطه بنكفير هو الذي يدعو للاجتياح
الاقصى
هذه التصريحات تصريحات قد تكون جميله ولكن
الواقعه مختلف
لا لا الواقع مش مختلف هناك نقاش بين بعض
الاطارات اليهوديه
المتطرفه مثل ما هو الحال ولكن بدون عنف
الذي ياتي من المتطرفين الاسلاميين من
امثال الحماس والجهاد هناك امر ينهي اي
زياره يهود في داخل الاقصى لاسباب دينيه
يهوديه من الفخامه الرئيسي الاسرائيلي وفي
الهوانش يقفوا من ناحيه المذهب الديني
شخصيات من
فكرتك دكتور خليني اسمعني
انه يعني اسرائيل خلال الفت الاخيره لمده
13 اسبوعا شهدت مظاهرات شارك في اكثر من
ربع مليون يهودي وبعض العرب ايضا في هذه
المظاهرات لنرى ان الشرطه دخلت واقتحمت
وقتلت وفعلت مثل ما تفعله في الاقصى اليوم
انا اسمع في الابحاث التي تجري في اسرائيل
او في قبل الكائنات يقولون ان هذه خطه
حماس وضعتها لكي تفجر وضعك الاقصى طب اذا
كنتم تعرفون ان هناك خطه لحماس لماذا
تنجرون وراءه ما الذي يجعل الجندي
الاسرائيلي يدخل ببسطاره الى قاعه الصلاه
في المسجد الاقصى كان بامكانهم ان يبقوا
خارج الصوره ولا يحدث اي اصداء القضيه
الاساسيه هي تلك الاقتحامات ما الذي
يرمونه منها هو خدمه الفعل هي فئه متطرفه
اكيد الغالبيه الساحقه من المتدين اليهود
يرفضون ان يدخلوا اليهود ويقتحوا الاقصى
ولكن هناك فئه اقليه لكن هذه الاقليه
اليوم موجوده في الحكم فيها وزير في وزاره
الدفاع فيها وزير مسؤول عن الشرطه ويريد
ان ي قيم ميليشيات مسلحه لان الشرطه لا
تقوم بما يكفي من عنف ضد الفلسطينيين
الشرطه الان تنافس هذه الميليشيا وتحاول
ان تثبت انها تستطيع ان تمارس العنف هذه
الحقيقه ما يجري في اسرائيل هو صراع داخلي
يكبون شرهم فيه على الفلسطينيين ويستغل
الدمون الفلسطينيين سلاحا في هذا الصراع
الداخلي وهذا امر لا يلغي الخطوره لن
نتائجه كارثيه للجهتين اسمح لي انا انقل
هذه النقطه للدكتوره زين دكتور ضيف اطرح
سؤال مشروع يطرحه الكل في الواقع هو يقول
طالما الحكومه الاسرائيليه تدرك بنوايا
حماس ونوايا بقيه الفصائل الاسرائيليه
لماذا تستفزهم في شهر فضيل وفي مكان هي
قادره ان لا تدخل من الاساس دخلت الشرطه
الشرطه دخلت اخرجت المصلين كسرت الابواب
كسرت الشبابيك
لماذا هذه الخطوه من هو المنتفع منها
سيد التين الفاضله يعني للاسف ضيفك الكريم
لا يقول الحقيقه ولا اريد ان استعمل كلام
غير لايك ومن ذلك ونحن كذلك لا نتمنى ذلك
تفضل
تفضل تفضل
شكرا لك انا كنت عقيد في شرطه
مستشار الشؤون العربيه منذ سنين في شتى
الحكومات التي سبقت هذه الحكومه
ودائما يخلق رجلات حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
واحيانا حتى رجالات السلطه الفرجيه يحردون
في هذا الشهر الفضي
لخلق مشاكل ولخلط جو من حرب دينيه وكانه
اليهود يريدون محاربه الاسلام ولا يفهم
ضيفك الكريم انه المؤامره التي تحيطها
التنظيمات الارهابيه تبع حماس والتي من
خلالها يرمون حجاره على
من داخل المسجد الاقصى حجار ويطعنون
بالسكاكين ويرمون يعني قضايا المتفجره او
المصلين لليهود وكانه هذا لا يعتبر الشرطه
ملزمه غير الايراداتها لعدمه التدخل الى
الاقصى ملزمه بالدخول ولم الاحجار
وايقاف هؤلاء المشاغبين قبل ان يحصل هذه
الامور واقول لك سيدتي الكريمه
فقط اسمحلي للتعليق لانه هناك مشاهدين
يتابعون ونحن نحترم كذلك مستوى متابعينا
حضرتك تقول بان الشرطه تدخل الى المسجد
الاقصى في جمع الحجاره دكتور عوفين فقط
اسمح لي بالتعليق لانه هناك مشاهدين وهناك
متابعين لتفاصيل واحتراما لمستواهم كذلك
في تلقي المعلومه حضرتك تقول بان الشرطه
تدخل لبحت المس اقصى لجمع الحجاره
ملزمه ملزمه مش بميتها من زمان منعا
لرمز احجار على المصلين اليهود والاستغلال
المكان المقدس للمسلمين
الاسلامي
والسبب من وراه ذلك هو خلف جو مشحون ديني
باثاره وضحت هذه الفكره خلينا ندخل اكثر
في الجانب السياسي دكتور وضحت هذه الفكره
خلينا نحاول فهم الجانب السياسي كذلك من
كل ما يحدث
في تطوراته استاذ نظير الحكومه حكومه
نتنياهو اتت ببرنامج عمل يمس بصلاحيات
الجيش الحكومه حاولت تمرير خطه الانقلاب
على منظومه الحكم واضعاف الجهاز القضائي
مما فجر مظاهرات في داخل الاسرائيلي
وهناك الال اف الذين خرجوا مظاهرات
احتجاجيه نظمت كل سبت الاسبوع الثالث عشر
وفي 130 نقطه كل هذا فجاه انتهى مع
التصعيد الذي شهدناه في المسجد الاقصى كيف
يفسر ذلك هل تعتقد بانه يعني انتهت القصه
انتهت المظاهرات او ان هذه مرحله هذه خطوه
فقط او تهدئه مرحليه لاكثر
لا لم تنتهي مظاهرات انا اعتقد ان
المظاهره يوم السبت القادم ستكون للاسبوع
الرابع عشر ربما لن تكون بنفس الدقامه لان
اليهود يعني يعيدون عيد الفصح اليهودي
والعبري وكل عام وهم بخير ونحن نريد ان
يكونوا بخير ولكن ليس في هذا التدهور
الامني الذي نرى نتائجه وقال فالمعارضه
الاحتجاج الاسرائيلي وجاء لانقاذ اسرائيل
من تيار يميني متطرف ظلامي ياتي بسياسه
جديده في الوقت الذي يتحرر فيها العالم
نحو التنور هم يعيدون اسرائيل الى
الظلاميه الى قوانين قمعيه فيها تقييد ليس
فقط للقضاء تقييد للاعلام فيها ضمن
المشاريع القوانين التي يريدون سنها ايضا
قوانين تمنع احزاب عربيه من الانتظام في
الانتخابات والمشاركه في الانتخابات فيها
العديد من الضربات لكل الجهاز الديمقراطي
ضرب للاقتصاد الاسرائيلي لذلك نرى ان قوى
عزيز
عديده جدا وحسب استطلاعات الراي تشكل
حوالي 63 بالمئه من المواطنين في اسرائيل
يؤيدون هذه الاحتجاجات ضد خطه الحكومه
الحكومه اليوم تعيش في وضع ضائقه هي لم
تتوقع استاذ نظير هل تعتقد بان هذا الضغط
من الدوله العميقه في داخل اسرائيل قد
يضطر الحكومه
لمراجعه او على مراجعه حساباتها او انه قد
يؤثر على الحكومه وتمسكها
هو اولا يؤثر ولذلك راينا ان الحكومه علق
او رئيس الحكومه علق هذه الاجراءات هنالك
تلاعب هنالك محاوله للتامر
لاستئناف الجهود في المستقبل القريب كله
يتوقف على رد الفعل الاسرائيلي في الشارع
طالما هنالك حمله احتجاج واسعه بهذا الشكل
يشارك فيها قوه من الجيش ومن الشرطه ومن
المواطنين ومن الجهاز الاقتصادي
والاكاديميا وكل هذه القوه التي تشكل
الدوله العميقه عندئذ انا اعتقد ان
نتنياهو سيتردد في الاستمرار فيها لان
الاستمرار فيها ايضا بدا يترك اثرا على
علاقه اسرائيل في الخارج الولايات المتحده
الاداره الامريكيه قياده اليهود في
الولايات المتحده الاوروبيون واصدقاء
اسرائيل يقولون يجب انقاذ اسرائيل من
نفسها انها تورط نفسها في ظروف
نعم بظروف يبدو باننا فقدنا صوت ضيفنا من
الناصره النظير اعود لك بعد قليل استاذ
نظير ولكنك طرحت نقطه امكانيه ان يتراجع
نتنياهو عن خطته وهذه النقطه انقلها لك
دكتور رؤوفين نتنياهو قادر على ان يراجع
حساباته خاصه وان اليوم هناك جبهتين
مفتوحتان امامه الجبهه الاولى هي جبهه
المظاهرات وهي يجب ان تؤمن وهذه المظاهرات
موسعه والجبهه الثانيه عندما يتعلق
الموضوع بالمسجد الاقصى قد ينفلت الامر في
اي ثانيه
مع كل احترام هنا مجرد السؤال يقلد شعبان
برمضان المظاهرات الاسرائيليه هي
المظاهرات التي نشهدها في الشارع هي من
مجرى قانوني
اؤيده
بمجرد انه من مظاهر الديمقراطيه الصحيحه
ونقول اذا انتبهتي يرفع علم اسرائيل
هو حقيقه دكتور انا انتبهت ولكن لا اتحدث
عن الديمقراطيه فدخل الاسرائيلي دكتور فقط
اسمح لي
الديمقراطيه في داخل الاسرائيلي اتحدث عن
المظاهرات هذه المظاهرات تعلم شرطي يؤمن
على نقاش بيناتنا بينما
داخل اسرائيل
تفضل شوفي انت عملتي مقابله عظيمه مع نفسك
ارجو ان اجاوبك على سؤالك لك
الوقتيه والعلاقه الوحيده ما بينها وبين
الاقصى هي انه هؤلاء يحتجون بشكل شرعي لان
ضد حكومه انتخبت باغلبيه الساحقه 64 مقعد
من ضمن 120 وهذا ليس له لك الا بشرط واحد
اعضاء اسرائيل يراهنون على الضعف الحكومه
عندما يتم هذه الاحتجاجات الديمقراطيه في
الشوارع وكانه اسرائيل ضعفت ولذلك
بعد ضرر الجراك حماس وجه هذه الانظمه
الفاصله الاخرى باثاره المشاكل العمده في
الاقصى اسرائيل قطر
والاكثر
ولا احد يريد ان يعتدي على الاقصى على ذلك
منذ تحرير القدامه وستين لم يقع فيه ولكن
فقط لانه هذا لم يكن سؤالي حضرتك
يعني لم يكن سؤالي انا تحدثت عن ان هذه
المظاهرات هي تؤمن بالاف اعضاء الشرطه
ولكن في جهه مقابله هناك كذلك تطورات
يشهدها المسجد الاقصى سؤالنا كان بسيط هل
يراجع نتنياهو حساباته
ليس هناك مجال لمراجعه اي حسابات اي ارهاب
في اي مكان في اسرائيل او خارجها يعالج
بيد من الحديد ليس لذلك اي علاقه بين
المظاهرات واقامه الشرطه بخطواتها زيد
المتظاهرين هنا او في القدس او زيد
المتطرفين اليهود في شوارع القدس كل سؤال
طالما عدت لنا ان لم يراجعنا نتنياهو
حساباته هل يمكن ان تؤثر على منصبه نتحدث
عن ضغط داخلي وضغط خارجي كنت اشرت له منذ
قليل
نعم بالتاكيد عليها ان يراجع حساباتي
واعتقد انه يراجع
والسبب في هذا ان النتيجه ستكون ازمه
دستوريه يعني اسرائيل اذا لم تحل المشكله
الان في قضيه هذه القوانين سينشئ وضعه
يكون فيه قرارات للمحكمه وسيكون امام
المسؤولين وزراء او شرطه او جيش ان يتخذوا
قرار هل يلتتر للاوامر الوزير او لعوامر
المحكمه وبامام ازمه مثل دستوريه كهذه
النتيجه دائما كانت في اي مكان في العالم
الحلقه ساشكركم جزيلا شكرا من الناصره
نظير مجلي المحلله السياسيه ومن تل ابيب
روف اني سابق ومحاضر شكرا لكم على
المشاركه السلام عليكم